when the doom claim Valyria the great
freehold fractured into warring cities
and upstart nations right for the taking
how to be swarmed the Dothraki the horse
Lords of the plains who feared only
defeat and Dragons and how the Dragons
were all gone under the great Khal temmo
they sacked and burnt every town and
city in their path no army could stand
against them because the Dothraki do not
stand the horselords do not draw up
battle lines or hide behind shield walls
or lair themselves in armor but the
frackie charge their blades are more
scythe and sword are better to call the
infantry ranks without breaking stride
even their archers far from horseback so
that advancing or retreating the arrows
never cease to the Dothraki a man who
does not ride is no man at all without
honor or pride when the city of qohor
realized Khal temmo was coming they
strengthened their walls doubled the
roam guards and hired two full companies
of cell swords the Dothraki were used to
glorified farmers with Spears coho would
show them a proper army with mounted and
armoured cavalry to match the hordes own
as an afterthought the city leaders sent
an inverter as too poor to buy unsullied
the slavers had always claimed that the
unsullied were the great ghiscari
legions come again few cared the Dragon
burnt ruins of old geese were a stark
reminder that the age of the foot
soldier was over then boy had his orders
however and quickly bought 3,000
unsullied for the long march back for
unsullied do not ride
but while they marched Khal temmo
arrived at Kuo Hall I can imagine how
pleased the car was to finally face a
challenge by the end of the battle crows
and wolves feasted on what remained of
Kuo [ __ ] heavy [ __ ] all the sell
swords had fled qohor knew that the
Dothraki would very soon break through
the gates to rape slave and burn at
their pleasure yet the next day cult MO
woke to find before the gates three
thousand eunuchs in formation armed with
only Spears shields and spiked helms the
unsullied had slipped past the cars army
in the night while the Dothraki feasted
carlton had many times their number and
could easily have flanked the small
force but to the Dothraki men on foot
half it only to be ridden down 18 times
the horselords charged an 18 times the
unsullied locked their shields lowered
their spears and held the line against
20,000 off rocky screamers when the
car's arch has rained arrows on them the
unsullied lifted their shields above
their heads until the squall passed and
then they held the line in the end only
six hundred unsullied remain but more
than twelve thousand or a keel a dead
including carlton MO and all his sons
the new car led the survivors past the
city gates where one by one each man cut
off his braid and threw it down before
the feet of the unsullied defeated and
shamed forever since that day the
unsullied filled the ranks of cities and
households wealthy enough or desperate
enough sell swords fight for gold
knights for glory and Dothraki for blood
to a man the unsullied fight only to
obey
with the right master over them imagine
how the forces of chaos would break
against their shields the conquerors the
madmen the usurpers